hi I'm Mike Madison Yale College
83 in the past chair of the Association
of Yale alumni welcome to the live
stream of the web forum for alumni in
connection with the search for the next
president of Yale I'm here as the
moderator in my role as alumni counselor
to the Presidential Search Committee I
am joined today by two members of the
committee I'll ask each of them to
introduce themselves thank you Mike my
name is chip good year I and the present
on the chairman of the search committee
for the next president of Yale I was
Pearson class of nineteen eighty and I'm
also a member the corporation hi I'm
Donna Dubinsky Yale class of 77 je since
we're doing colleges and I am a member
of the Yale Corporation and a member of
the search committee when I'm not on
Yale business I am a technology
entrepreneur based in California thanks
Mike I'm Rick Lifton I'm sterling
professor and chair of the department of
genetics in the medical school here at
Yale my background is I came to Yale as
an assistant professor in 1993 and i've
been here since my laboratory works on
discovering genes that contribute to
human diseases that range from cancer to
cardiovascular disease our most recent
contribution has been the development of
new technology for sequencing all the
genes in the human genome very rapidly
and inexpensively and this has enabled
us to make the first genetic diagnosis
by DNA sequencing of a young child at
the genome level Yale was been a
spectacular place for me and my family
as I've been here over the last 20 years
and I'm pleased to be with you today so
the question is in addition to capacity
for successful leadership of Yale as an
educational institution to what degree
is the search committee prioritizing
capacity to inspire service to society
that is so much a part of Gail's history
and tradition there's no doubt this is a
very important part of Yale's history
and tradition and it's something that I
think we're seeing undergraduates have
more and more interest in and feel as
more and more important it's it's been
very interesting to watch the evolution
I think from my general
in the current generation where we see
students feeling this is just critically
important to have in a future president
to continue these kind of activities
from Whitehall to fellowships to service
abroad to all sorts of different
activities so I think this is something
that the next president needs to value
and that that will look for as a as a
strength absolutely i would agree and if
you look at Yale's mission statement
which is something that probably you
don't do very often you'll see that the
last comment is talking about leadership
in scholarship in in society and in the
professions and that society part is
actually part of Yale's mission let's
transition to a something that talks
about international experience and this
goes not just to Yale's presence
internationally but also to the
attributes of the president immersed
himself or herself so the question of
the comment really for reflection is
this as Yale aspires to take its place
as a global university and to ensure its
full international credentials I believe
says they were right the alum that the
next president of Yale should have lived
and worked outside the US for several
years only by living in a different
culture will the true sensitivity of the
next president be more heightened the
perspective of looking at one's own
nation and culture from the eyes of an
expatriate is truly eye-opening what do
you think I think that is a wonderful
question and statement I think that
that's been my experience I've spent 15
years living overseas from Australia to
China to the UK and as captured in that
in that question / comment you can't
appreciate the u.s. the world what's
happening around the globe until you've
actually lived in a different society
and I have to say though that's a very
rare opportunity it'd be nice if we
could give everybody that chance and as
you know Yale is trying to do that with
their with their undergraduates and I
think making a very good very good very
good progress in that direction with
regard to whether the next president
will have had that experience clearly
I'd see it as a positive but we also
have to look at it in the context of
those people that the
people that may be on that list of
candidates and if they've lived over
there that's great we can't put that as
a hard and fast because again we are
evolving as a global community where
that cross-border experience of living
and working is still not something that
that all generations have had a chance
to do so let's be a little bit more
focused on the international aspect and
turn to the topic of yells partnership
with the National University of
Singapore and the launch of the Yale and
us college question is from an alum
president Levin has said that the Yale
and us college in Singapore will figure
as an important part of his presidential
legacy my question is how the future of
this college will figure in interviews
with candidates to replace president 11
sure let me take that first of all as i
said earlier Yale's commitment to the
globalization is is crystal clear it
comes from the corporation has the
support and there's many things that
have happened in that globalization
activity during president Levin's tenure
it's as i mentioned students living
overseas and having part of their
experience as undergraduates overseas
it's involved the world Fellows Program
it's obviously involved many people
coming to the Yale campus from overseas
to share their experience I yale-nus is
another example of the implementation of
that globalization process and that is
something that is moving forward and
will our conversations with the with the
candidates for the next president of
Yale involved globalization you bet it
will whether yale-nus is part of that
that's going to be a function of what
they know and what questions they have
but we're certainly perfectly willing to
talk about that and again we see it as
one of the key elements of that and it
will be part of the conversation in some
way so we certainly will a lot of that
discussion from the alumni's perspective
in terms of the comments that we've
received a lot of the comments in a
number of the questions that came in
really take that kind of diversity and
reduce it to us or of a single axis a
number of alumni have asked questions
and raised concerns about the next
president
focus on and interest in the humanities
and making sure that Yale's traditional
strengths and the humanities are
preserved respected and supported and
related to that traditional strengths in
the arts including the professional
schools in the arts art architecture
drama and music on the other end of that
same spectrum are alumni who have said
fairly directly in some of the questions
we've received I believe that Yale
should appoint a scientist or should
appoint an engineer as its next
president because of the emerging and
obvious importance of science and
technology and modern life whether
that's the internet and computer
technology or biotechnology genetic
engineering and all of that the
importance of those things in daily life
those things in terms of the research
life of the University the importance of
those things in the teaching and the
educational experience that our students
are exposed to and what if you could
comment on how that issue is reflected
in the committee's deliberations yeah I
think I would come back to the general
point and I think we've benefited in the
last 20 years virtually the entire time
I've been here Rick Levin has been the
president at Yale and I think one of his
strongest qualities has been his ability
to understand issues that arise in the
whole Academy that exists at Yale and so
I think people on who have been on the
faculty during that time have recognized
that particularly just speaking from my
own experience as a faculty member in
the medical school that Rick is not
medically trained he doesn't have a
background in the sciences I yet and yet
he was very effective at understanding
key issues in the development of the
sciences at the Medical School across
his tenure and so I have come to the
position and the understanding that you
don't need a direct experience in the
discipline in order to be able to
understand the issues but you have to be
very open-minded very inquisitive and a
very quick study and I think these are
issues that will I think we will be
looking for in the next president I
fortunately think there is no necessary
dichotomy between
being interested in the humanities and
being interested in the sciences I think
most people that you find on the Yale
campus are broadly inquisitive and
genuinely take advantage of the full
range of activities that exists here at
at Yale and in the local community and
that really is one of the tremendous
strengths of Yale the cost of attending
Yale is extraordinary is the the face
amount of tuition and other expenses
both for undergraduates and for graduate
and professional students a Yale so what
what role is the cost of a yell
education playing and you're thinking
about identifying yells ex-president
earth is there trying to reduce the cost
or otherwise support students and access
to education if you could reflect on on
those themes a bit would be helpful you
know it's a problem it's a problem not
just at Yale but clearly through the
whole country it's it's just a really
hard problem in terms of the escalation
of costs in the research universities I
think particularly it's it's expensive
you know getting great faculty is
expensive building great facilities is
expensive and doing incredible
world-class research is expensive all
these things are expensive the
interesting thing though when you dig
into the numbers is that actually
tuition as high as it is which I agree
only cover something like thirty percent
of the cost of Yale College so
fortunately we're able to supplement
that cost through the earnings of our
endowment and our fabulous team there
that's managed endowment as well as the
generosity of our alumni and friends who
have continued to support the University
and that helps supplement the cost of
that tuition so if we actually ask
people to pay the full amount it would
be a great deal more of course it's
critically important in our view and we
hope in the next president's view that
we enable access to a Yale education by
those who don't afford it I not sure the
number thing something like fifty
percent of the students get some sort of
financial aid so it's a very large
number we have needs blind admissions
we don't let that stop people from
attending Yale but at the same time we
have to work harder to get a grip on
these costs we just have to figure out
how to do it and we have worked on that
there's a lot of things being done in
the administrative area to be more
efficient in the areas where we can to
do better job on infrastructure on
information technology all these things
I think can help make us more efficient
and can save money but but it's a hard
problem it's something that I know brick
is very live in your world in the
medical school which is technology
transfer and the impact of the
university's research program on the
community around it and for example
Yale's engagement not only with the city
of New Haven but also the the transfer
of the Yale's research into the world at
large how much of a priority are those
issues to the search committee and the
appointment of the next president so I
think it's critical to recognize that
there is a role for technology transfer
in developing the economy in the region
certainly there are biotechnology
corridors that are better developed than
New Haven Boston and the Bay Area come
immediately to mind where spin-offs
coming out of the university have really
helped fuel the local economy I think
critical to that is not losing the point
that Yale's primary mission is not to
create new companies and new jobs that
is something that might happen as a
consequence of work that goes on in
basic research but is not the purpose of
a university but being able to transfer
that technology out in a way that can
support these other missions I think is
a useful benefit this is from an alum
who writes Yale is behind the times
computer wise whether in web-based
courses or in the multitude of other
uses both known and unknown and not
likely to be developed at Yale with all
due respect it appears that this is a
serious deficiency and we need to fix it
you want to reflect on this book from
the standpoint of a member of the board
of trustees the corporation and also
from the standpoint
member of the faculty and how it impacts
you think it impacts the lives of the
students and the faculty here well I'll
just comment on the point about Yale
strengths and weaknesses and I think if
you were to think about areas that Yale
could do better in I do think
computation and engineering or both
areas that Yale could be stronger in and
I think there's definitely room to
improve and grow those problems there's
very strong faculty here in those areas
but I think if you compare Yale to the
other leading research institutions
across the country those are areas that
we could stand further growth in when it
comes to education clearly we're in a
real transition in terms of how students
should be spending their time in the
balance between classroom time and time
spent outside the classroom engaged in
learning in different ways in the
medical school it's clear that many of
the traditional lecture courses really
don't have the same salience for our
students today that they did 20 years
ago but the density of information
transfer through a lecture frequently is
just not as good as what students can
achieve by other means and I think we
need to be thinking about how we use our
face-to-face classroom time and thinking
about using that more for interactive
problem-solving than for didactic
lectures yeah you know the use of
technology here is a real passion of
mine i come from the technology industry
i have worked with a group of other
alums through the years on a committee
we called digital yale to advise the
university i do think we're coming a bit
from behind here but i think we we have
more going on than a lot of people know
and some very exciting initiatives I
certainly want to point our alumni
community the open Yale courses which
are more about you know dissemination of
information than the
interactive teaching that goes on on
campus but some of our best professors
have have put their lectures up there
and there they're really fabulous
they're wonderful stuff worth checking
out in addition we have done some
experimentations for the last two
summers here at Yale of for credit
undergraduate courses with some of the
you know faculty that's been willing to
experiment and try to push this
technology forward and we've learned a
lot from that we've learned what things
to do with things not to do and we've
learned how to start to make that a
really great experience that a Yale
student could still interact with Yale
faculty but maybe be doing an internship
somewhere and still be able to pick up a
credit while they're away so so we're
doing work in that and and I think we've
got to do more and I think we will do
more so I think as the technologies
evolve and the platform's sort of
evolved and settle in we're going to be
paying close attention we're going to be
doing experimentation and the next
president is going to have to be helping
to lead this process of figuring out how
do we take advantage of the stuff to
help really improve learning and
education at Yale previously on behalf
of an alum about the the next presidents
international background how important
is it to the committee that the next
president of Yale come from within the
Yale family either somebody who has a
Yale degree has a yale college degree or
is presently a member of the y OU
faculty or administration you know we've
talked quite a bit about that and we've
had a lot of input on on that question
through the course of our discussions of
course on and I would say that you know
it's it's would be a real plus to have
somebody who has some Yale interaction
some may be having been part of the
faculty now or at some point in the past
having been a student you know that's
those are all I think they would be
viewed as pluses we don't think however
it's it's a must-have we think it is
possible that there could be a great
leader who is from another institution
if they're able to listen absorb a
culture relate to people well that they
could also be extremely successful so
we've kind of put it in the column of
nice to have a plus but not an absolute
requirement you know in my inbound
alumni counselor mailbox there have been
a number of themes that have recurred
over and over and the hundreds of emails
that I've gotten so far and one of them
is globalization and
internationalization we've talked about
that a second one is athletics and the
role of athletics at Yale and the
traditions of athletics at Yale and the
role of the president of Yale and the
leadership of Yale in supporting
athletes supporting athletics supporting
our athletic teams so let me just set
that as the the foundational sort of
theme for what I think will be two or
three questions here so the first
comment is please select a president who
values and emphasizes athletics Yale has
a rich tradition of athletics countless
Olympians the oldest collegiate rugby
club the second most national football
championships in the NCAA this person
writes I was not a varsity athlete but
one of my criteria for applying to any
college was that they had a tradition of
athletics especially football being a
fan alongside a sea of others is one of
the greatest experience anyone can have
at college I understand that Yale will
not and should not sacrifice academic
excellence in order to grab the top
recruits but Stanford is certainly on
our level academically yet it is one of
the best athletic schools in the country
as well so this is a theme that clearly
touches the entire student experience
not just the lives of athletes but
clearly I've heard also from athletes
themselves about their experiences and
their desire to have support and
reinforcement for their efforts and
their ambitions as part of their yellow
experience like that comment on that
anyway you know we've gotten a lot of
feedback on this issue I think we've
heard the message loud and clear and I
think it's important to say that
athletics is important at Yale it's it's
a part of the fabric of the community I
think it's incredibly important for
learning leadership skills team skills
learning about winning and losing I
think it's important just for the
community that's something that kind of
rally behind the teams it has to fit
into our overall Yale community you know
one of the wonderful things about Yale
is is
how many of these passions there are
whether it's you know the people are
doing social justice and out working in
the community and teaching kids you know
in the New Haven community or whether
it's the Whiffenpoofs there there are
lots and lots of different things where
people can direct their energies learn
leadership skills learn team skills be a
part of something that helps bring us
all together so you know I think that
any discussion with any future president
is going to make sure that they have the
same view of athletics as an important
component of the Yale community in the
Yale experience it just seems like that
that would be a part of what we would
want to see I don't chip was chip was an
athlete so I think you know ship may
have other views on this well known i
think that's right Donna I think the
comment that athletics fits in the
entire tapestry of what Gail is about
but it does bring many of the things we
talked about that mission statement and
the contribution to society and those
issues of leadership and teamwork and so
on are things we want to we want to
emulate in people who will obviously
take leadership roles around the world I
spent four years with the rowing on the
crew here at Yale John rice is also a
member of the search committee and the
corporation John played basketball at
Yale so we do have representation in
both the committee and the corporation
people who have had that experience I
would also say although the alumni have
also been quite interested in athletics
here the students are and it's not just
the student-athletes the students are
are very interested in Yale and yells
performance there are there are many
sports we do quite well in and we see
that record and that's great to have and
we want those things it brings that
camaraderie that I did to tear your they
could comment captured and and that's
important again in the tapestry of what
we're all about as you said we're not
going to be an Alabama we're not going
to be as a Texas in the guard of the
football field but but can we have
programs that give us things that we can
rally around it certainly is part of
that tapestry
we're about so if we could turn a little
bit to a new topic I'm going to
characterize this as campus climate and
in this area the questions come from
different perspectives and raised
different themes but i think that they
all could be grouped as their campus
climate questions so the first comment
is I think these are all going to be
provocative to be honest but the first
is obviously provocative the alum writes
I have been concerned that Yale has been
leaning more and more extremely to the
political left and i hope you will
choose someone who is relatively a
political or even conservative and
prioritize learning and teaching over
political whims i can i can take my
thoughts on that we say in the search
statement that and i think we're pretty
clear than the area of ethics in the
area of excellence those things there's
not a scale to that so those two things
are a must-have and we have a list of
criteria and listen we're going to have
to trade off on those things but when we
think about the next president of Yale
and that issue of performance we don't
qualify it by gender we don't qualify it
by religion we don't qualify it by race
and we don't qualify it by political
leanings one way or another I would
guess as far back certainly as far back
as I can remember it's always been gay
leans to the left when you look at some
of the surveys of students you don't
necessarily see quite that so the the
additional theme that i think is brought
out by the changes since the mid-1970s
is not only the changing nature of
college athletics but also the changing
nature of the role of women and not just
in sport but in the in the university in
general and so i wanted to draw that out
and and I've had a number of alumni
contact me as part of this search
process and say in effect it's time for
Yale to appoint a woman as the president
of Yale and and related to that are
related themes about gender the recent
research that was discussed in the new
york times about subconscious bias
sciences with respect to women if you
could comment on how the committee might
have discussed or might view gender and
other diversity concerns with respect to
the search well we want to make sure we
have a very diverse pool to look at
there's no doubt that you know we have
hundreds of names on our list at this
point and many women and
underrepresented minorities and a vast
array of people I think in the end when
it comes to selection what's most
critical to us is to get the best
possible person and that is irrespective
of gender of race of whether they're
international or not or you know any
specific characteristic we needed to be
somebody who respects diversity and it's
somebody who really values that and as
an integral part of that out of the
campus but I don't think that that we
feel that should should dictate you know
the that person themselves a specifics
of that person I think it's really
important to be aware of the potential
for hidden bias and to make sure that
that's taken into account I think it's
fair to acknowledge that other
universities have appointed women as
president I think it would be a
wonderful thing if Yale were two to do
that we also have produced presidents
who have come from Yale and gone on to
very successful careers as presidents at
other institutions and that I think it
would be terrific to have a woman
president at Yale you should just yet a
different topic which is the city of New
Haven under Rick Levin's leadership
anyone who's been back to campus over
the last 15 years has seen a remarkable
turnaround still in progress but it's
our the demeanor of New Haven and of the
demeanor of Yale's engagement with new
haven in a variety of senses in terms of
the physical presence of the university
and how it engages with the community
but also of course this has a lot to do
with the interaction between the
University and the residents of New
Haven just in terms of day-to-day life
and also in terms of dl's relationship
with its labor unions so I wondered if
you could comment on how Yale's evolving
relationship with New Haven
present your thinking about the future
of the University and the role of the
next president you know what one thing
that I was really remarking on in all
the meetings I've had with particularly
with faculty and staff who reside here
in New Haven when you ask you know
what's gone well at Yale over the past
10 to 20 years this is number one on
their list people are are so excited and
happy and grateful for the work that has
been done to improve relations with with
the city and to make this a great place
to live how was the presidential search
committee constructing the pool of
candidates well the pools is coming from
a lot of places first of all thank you
my key or the alumni have written in
with with many suggestions of
nominations we've had many suggestions
from people on campus of course and
we've also been working with a
professional search firm who knows a lot
of the community outside of the
community here and into international
around the world so they have helped us
to complete the list in in other ways
and I shouldn't say complete the list
because the list keeps growing we
continue to take interesting ideas about
people to look at so it's really been
from a lot of different places that
we've been getting input for possible
candidates we're continuing our our
outreach discussions those will continue
on again we never want to stop listening
to what people are hearing or telling us
and again it's that unusual thing that
may that may be very helpful to us that
we would love to hear about we are now
moving into the process of taking our
list and moving it down we will begin a
series of conversations with individuals
as we get to that point the wind part is
we want to move on an expedited basis
but we're not going to race to simply
get the job over with we are going to
identify what we believe is the the the
best few candidates to present to the
corporation for their decision and what
I would say is that this is not only an
opportunity to think about the next
president of Yale it's a great
opportunity to think
and the fact that we are using this and
have the real privilege to talk to
students faculty alumni the city and
staff and so on is really just as I say
it's a great privilege
you